Bild ist im Stau und viele Menschen auch
wegen der klimakaoten auch heute wieder
hunderte Meter lang der ganz normale
Alltag der klimakleber die uns den
Alltag erschweren eigentlich gut in der
Sache aber schlecht in der Umsetzung
heute aber rechnen wir uns ohne Kleber
dafür mit Humor Bildreporter Rick
Schütze der versucht die klimakaoten von
der Straße weg zu lachen
sie kleben wieder hier mitten in Berlin
am Frankfurter Tor angeblich sei der
Klimawandel nicht aufzuhalten so sagen
sie für sie ist das Bittere ernst und
sie die klimakräger verstehender
überhaupt keinen Spaß oder
wir fragen uns immer so habt ihr
eigentlich Humor
ich habe ich habe auch einen Witz
mitgebracht also pass auf
der eine Gletscher sagt zum anderen
Gletscher sag mal pass auf du schuldest
mir noch 1000 Euro sagt der zweite
Gletscher warte mal kurz bald bin ich
wieder flüssig
ich habe ich habe noch einen zweiten
mitgebracht
woran erkennt man ein grüner
geben sie mal zu an der Farbe Grün
natürlich nicht an der Farbe rot oder
also mit dem Witzen hat schon mal nicht
geklappt darauf haben die irgendwie
nicht so reagiert
ich glaube ich weiß wie ich diese
Aussage einfach mal fragen ob ich die
kitzeln darf oder vielleicht wenn man da
rumsitzt juckt es ja auch irgendwo da
habe ich noch so einen kleinen Kratzer
mitgebracht mal sehen
hi ist schon wieder aber ich wollte mal
fragen
wenn hier die ganze Zeit so rum setzt
vielleicht kann man dich ja zum Lachen
bisschen bringen die mich Dich kitzeln
[Musik]
vielleicht auch der Rücken ich habe auch
noch ein Kratzer mit da könnte ich da wo
es jetzt ist deine Chance jetzt zu sagen
da möchte ich mal gekratzt werden
[Musik]
also kitzeln und Katzen hat auch
irgendwie nichts gebracht wie kriegen
wir die denn jetzt ein bisschen
aufgemuntert uns reden ich habe noch was
was immer zieht
echte vegane Fairtrade außen Biohandel
gemachte Süßigkeiten und das versuchen
wir jetzt mal vielleicht klappt ja das
[Musik]
letzter Versuch kann ich dir
kann ich dir vielleicht was Süßes tun
wenn du sitzt hier die ganze Zeit nicht
dass ihr verholt ist vegan Fairtrade und
aus dem Bier also Umwelt
ist echt lecker schon gekostet
aber dann habe ich okay jetzt ziehe ich
alle Register damit die hier nicht so
langweilig ist habe ich dir auf jeden
Fall eine Zeitung mitgebracht die lege
ich dir mal hier vorne hin super
[Musik]
dann werde ich mal gucken wie die
Autofahrer so drauf sind vielleicht
reagieren die auf mein Angebot
willst du ein
ist vegan Fairtrade
wie viel Humor haben sie noch gar kein
darf ich sie mal einen Witz erzählen sie
lachen so schön also was ist rot und
gefährlich für die Zähne
ein Backstein so und die andere Frage so
lange schon im Auto juckt es sie
irgendwo ich kann sie kratzen mit meinem
Kratzer die da vorne die verstehen
nämlich überhaupt keinen Humor ich habe
das den Angeboten die wollten nicht sie
vielleicht boah ja da einmal hinten da
gut
super vielen Dank und jetzt dürfen sich
auch vegan Fairtrade umweltfreundlich
eine Sache raussuchen
[Musik]
dann halten sie noch gut durch
was ist orange und geht gerne wandern
[Musik]
na eine Wanderin
sitze hier im Auto juckt es sie irgendwo
ich kann sie kratzen ja meine richtige
so
super und als Dankeschön echte
umweltfreundliche Fairtrade Bio
Schokolade greift zu vielen Dank
also die Autofahrer trotz des Stresses
den die jeden Tag hier erleben weil die
klimakauten sich da vorne festliebt
haben auf jeden Fall ihren Humor noch
nicht verloren
[Musik]